The United States has recognized
Juan Guaidó as the legitimate president
of Venezuela, launching an international
campaign to oust the narcodictator
Nicolas Maduro. More than 50 governments
have backed Guaidó as Venezuela's
constitutional president. Guaidó has
called on Maduro to cede power to a
transitional government and he has
attempted to win the Venezuelan military
to his cause. Thus far,
Maduro and his criminal cronies
have resisted US sanctions and
diplomatic pressure. They have amassed
fortunes from stolen oil revenue in
cocaine trafficking, so they have simply
too much to lose. US diplomats
have called on military leaders
to oust Maduro as well. However,
an April rebellion plotted by Guaidó's team
failed after producing only a
handful of defectors. Guaidó has now
agreed to negotiations, but Maduro may
only offer elections where the regime
holds all the cards. Many predict that
Maduro will never step aside for Guaidó,
unless he is forced out by Venezuelan
patriots fighting for their country.
Do you think the current US
strategy will produce a change in
Venezuela? Let us know in our poll, and
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and
be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.